also das geht nur durch einen akt der
beleihung das heißt dass messi muss der
landesgesetzgeber regeln und der
landesgesetzgeber muss dann auch im
detail regeln was genau diese privaten
sicherheitsdiensten die dann zu
hoheitlichen aufgaben herangezogen
werden auch tatsächlich dürfen
in der regel wird zum
überwachungsaufgaben gehen es wird darum
gehen dass auch platzverweise
ausgesprochen werden dürfen aber weitere
als rechte werden dann ausschließlich
bei den ordnungsämtern verbleiben ein
großes thema sind natürlich vor allem
die bußgelder die jetzt verhängt werden
sollen da es noch immer großer
flickenteppich in deutschland aber
dürften diese privaten sicherheitsleute
dann beispielsweise die 250 euro für
masken verweigerer die herr söder
angesprochen hat auch verhängen also die
ordnungsgelder werden nach wie vor dann
von den ordnungsämtern wörtlich verhängt
das hat dann mit den mit der übertragung
dieser aufgaben auf die privaten
sicherheitsdienste die im übrigen auch
qualifiziert und zertifiziert sein
müssen
wir möchten nicht dass jeder
herangezogen werden kann sondern wir
legen schon wert auf qualität
damit auch die akzeptanz in der
bevölkerung natürlich gegeben ist wie
schnell kann diese beleihung jetzt
stattfinden wie lange dauert es bis dann
tatsächlich diese sicherheitskräfte
genutzt werden können also wir brauchen
erstmal rechtliche regelungen und wir
werden jedenfalls jetzt noch mal durch
ein gutachten genau erklären lassen
unter welchen voraussetzungen das
möglich ist was die landesgesetzgeber
genau regeln müssen und dann hoffen wir
natürlich dass es dann möglichst schnell
geht wir haben es beim pakt für den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst gesehen
das ging relativ schnell
es gibt jetzt dreieinhalb milliarden 3,1
milliarden euro für zusätzliches
personal in den gesundheitsämtern und so
etwas ähnliches brauchen wir auch für
die ordnungsämter wir sind bild und wir
liefern dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht und seinen
kanal zu abonnieren